[Music]
hello and welcome to
i guess your midterm exam
um so today we have more of a full house
so this will be more interesting
uh
we are going to be looking at some
really cool puzzles
i kind of wanted to do a different style
because i did that in the camp and
what we did was like i would show 10
puzzles
you would keep the answers to yourself
and after the 10 puzzles were done you
would kind of come back circle back and
then you would give me the answers
that's something you did in the camp and
it was really fun but i don't think
that's as practical
because unfortunately
then the chat would have to stay silent
for 10 puzzles i don't think that's as
fun so we're just going to do it as
random
as usual
uh
i have 64 puzzles they're not supposed
to be too hard they're supposed to be
if you are like 1700 you should have an
easy time with them
some of them can be more challenging but
um
this is still supposed to be find the
checks attack the king find your ways
voila
okay
it's supposed to be a nice hour
you should not feel too pressured
all right i have some other news that
i'll share as we go
but i've been told i need to
first explain what we're doing in the
lesson the first stairs to 10 seconds
i never do that
so
let's jump right to it
the faster we solve the faster i get to
talk about stuff all right
first one white to move
what you're gonna do
bishop c5
and then many more yep
thank you i have
first audience so
first being solved by audience to be
fair they had a little more time on it
than you did
but yeah
it's a check it's a maintenance because
the king is stuck and whatever they do
rocket 3 will happen next cool great
if there any questions let me know we'll
circle back
if not let's keep moving on
all right cool i don't think they can
see the answer yay
so
again white to move
and this is uh
kind of funny because it's uh two people
that i actually know
white is spillman black is short
i think it's obstruction with knight g5
yeah that seems to be the very
interesting way to go for it because you
have full control over the seventh rank
so what you want to be able to do is
well use that idea so yeah knight g5 it
is
good choice
if black takes well that's gonna be a
fun checkmate oh actually sure
yeah
yeah
pretty fun right
if black doesn't take it how else are
they gonna be defending their seventh
rank
so yeah
white to move in this one
i'm also trying to see if there's
anything new in the chat
it's not supposed to be scary i had
something more
intriguing in mind but
um i'm having trouble seeing so i didn't
want to torture myself
let's say bishop h6 check so rook takes
h7 king takes bishop d3 bishop h6 check
maybe
then let's say
king g7 trying to run king f8
i don't think you're wrong but i do but
maybe
another minute on it and you should be
able to solve it for sure
bishop e3 first
the only problem i see with that is what
if i queen c7
do you know we have a grandmaster
somewhere in the audience
where
there yeah that's it thanks
actually i can see far better right now
than close
i had my eyes checked today yearly
checkup and they put
drops in and
everything feels a little
well i guess my eyes feel touched yep
so
oh i see that nikki thank you
happy early valentines to you too
i have a new medical school interview on
valentine's so
yay
thanks thanks this one is in texas
i have family there so i'm intrigued
it is white to play we've had some
really interesting ideas with
take this maybe bishop d3 some ideas
related to attack but we're trying to
find the correct move order so
so the problem
not the problem the question we're
trying to solve right now is after
bishop d3 this check
then what because let's say we just move
the king for argument's sake then
opponent king could try to run
and i we have to be kind of cautious on
that
because
we've had multiple episodes of slippery
dorsa so you almost when your opponent
gets
options they can try to run away so we
don't want slippery opponents
i'm having trouble reading cool
this is so weird
oh okay uh queen f5 with the idea of
them taking
yeah
i still like rook takes h17 bishop d3
i'm a big fan of that
see um
fits even if we do the queen h4 after
wreckage
after rick takes h7 there is still push
of h6 check that we have to deal with so
the only thing we're trying to figure
out is how to deal with this bishop h6
idea
this is proving to be more challenging
than i thought
we can but then what if king g7
probably still take on g6 king gotta go
to f8
that still feels pretty winning but
how do you actually continue are you
coming if that happens in the real game
are you comfortable
if you can't check
me hi
i do think rook h7 still is the best
move for the first
thing to do so rook takes h7 king takes
bishop d3 very logical
bishop h6
then what
that's the idea but first we have to
resolve the check
we have a develop suggestion from the
chat
there
okay i we agree with this
and then we talked about this
then what to do let's say you just move
the king not even funny stuff king g7
now what's
on g6 with queen or bishop
bear king king has to go to f8 because
if king gets straight that's checkmate
king fa denmark
this feels very close to winning
um
i think that's fine especially after
king e8 you might get bishop g6 but why
not just take this already
because if king e7 you can still do this
check or even this check
king has to go to d7
and
now maybe you can include this rook
i'm still a bigger fan of queen g sound
to be honest to kick that king to the
back rank then rook h1
even if you're trying to do funny
business like that
i'm very intrigued to just take this
keep it from running
another idea you could do even before
rookies one maybe this check
if king c7 haha
if king d7
i guess again the same idea then just
finish it up with the bishop
i guess the key idea to c is this queen
g7
and if king e8
we just don't want the king to go this
way so that's the one thing i think
we're trying to
avoid
i'm still considering just moving the
queen and moving the rook
but that might be a little slower than
intended
check up
check
up another check yeah i don't really
want that thing to run
yeah queen g7 anyhow still feels about
right even if you try to be smart about
it and do like knight d7 trying to block
it
i'm still comfortable playing rick h1
with 3kh8 ideas
yeah so i guess the main main
idea is to not take opponent too
seriously in this position realize yeah
there's other six exist all right i'll
just move my king and then even if even
if opponent tries to run with the king
great i'll just pick this up if opponent
goes king g
and g8 same idea if now tries to block
with the bishop
i even just want to give this chick
bishop of fate maybe then
rook h1 that also feels comfortable
so it's not just about the winning of
the the material eating but it's just
about okay opponent king is really weak
this is a winning position you don't
necessarily need to see every single
line but as long as your opponent's king
is kind of um
trapped
and your opponent doesn't really have a
good way of forcing okay if if opponent
could just do this then yeah i would be
a little concerned but i'm not really
concerned about this specific position
do we feel good about it
all right cool
yeah
yeah sorry it wasn't a concrete
continuation no it's not
it's the idea that you have to decide
here that this sacrifice is the best
followed by bishop d3 and then you have
to see those few ideas that okay if the
king tries to run away for example like
this how do i stop it and maybe just
kind of
be alright with the idea that okay i
might need to prolong it a little but
this is a winning position because
opponents just can't get their pieces
closed if opponent's knight was here
yeah i would i would think a little bit
deeper about this because this knight
can take here this knight could go
defend so
because this position is too
bad for opponent i'm good
there is a question from skull what is
this class a boy
a boy okay
i know
so this class we usually sit here
i drink tea and i talk about
life i'm kidding uh
we usually do different things we just
finished the ginormous sicilian for
white series so we're trying to
dial down from the opening and dive
deeper into
chess
we were considering changing this
class's name
but i really wanted to call it how to be
a knowing and that's not very user
friendly so we keep it in chess and
psychology
uh muhammad how do you know dennis boris
is here
he is here but how do you know
so there is a question about when to
terminate in the previous
puzzle i guess
you get a redemption idea here probably
because
again this is not you're not it's highly
unlikely you'll find
every single idea and just gonna go
until checkmate so you have to choose
what are you sacrificing
it could be knight bishop brook
i don't think a queen jack queen
sacrifices a sacrifice that's just
blunder at this point
dennis there's a muhammad bin
el-hajj who says hi to you
hi back
nice chat said rook takes h7 but then i
thought they had the intermediate uh
that takes e4 that's kind of funny
interesting ah
well
what if you just take it back then like
f takes e4 what if queen takes e4 or
queen h5
there's question on knight g5 i think 95
is also fine
but
i think in a real game you play knight
h5 you still hold a lot of advantage and
that's still be fine at the end of the
day but
if you if rick h7 works and you don't do
it
you're gonna have a hard time sleeping
that night
it looks like it works
it kind of feels like it too take take
so ah no
ah no no
yeah if king takes what do you do
okay
yep and there's no knight of six because
well that'll be fun
maybe actually
maybe check first den tank just to
torture them a little bit
if they take over here
yeah
trying to go over here yeah
same idea
i don't really see how black can hold it
i'm very curious on what the engine has
to say
ah
seriously i'm not going to play death
no nobody's going no no no no this if
this is sorry what
giving up everything to run
i mean
sure
black queen is in siberia
probably
why doesn't anybody ever say like why do
people say siberia why not like
australia because that's way farther
why
yeah population density
also it's just
australia is a weird country good but
i've never been but
geographic wise
how does this one feel for white
yeah somebody found a free bishop
hey
yeah i think this is a very very
interesting thing that the chat is
talking about too you have two nights
so with two nights you it kind of is
begging for some for some forking ideas
so what do we think
i mean the first move that comes to mind
is knight f6 but you can't play that
yeah so that's a little problematic that
doesn't really help us a whole lot right
now
i also saw a night h5 idea in the chat
uh but rook takes here and i don't see
what you're seeing
so
there was that idea
c4
um it doesn't work because the rook is
on the floor
yeah but even if the rook wasn't on the
four crank this check wouldn't really be
that helpful because the king could just
move away somewhere
i think you're thinking too much about
the king rather than your knights
this is a very fun thing to do if we can
the question is how can we
what defender
your kingdom itself is also not super
strong so ideally if you could exchange
off even more stuff
queen takes f5
knight six queen takes g4
uh
g4 knight f6 check in 14 yeah
thank you
yeah
yeah i had a few people who also
mentioned 905 so good job chad good job
in person
yay all right
and even if you don't take it the
even if let's say you try to move the
rock
uh
i'm still very comfortable in this
position what do i want to do do i want
to eat this do i want to eat this
questions
i think honestly eating on d6 would also
just be comfortable because you pick up
two pawns
even if the bishop manages to somehow
move away i'm not really terribly
worried about that
let's say rook g1 maybe to be a little
bit more
on the funny side
yep
so i think if the rook does want to move
g6 might be the only reasonable square i
mean maybe a four what if rook f4
this is also a
problem for black so rook g6 seems to be
the only
possibility and then maybe even queen h5
because i still want to do this
i'm not giving up on your rook
could be interesting
sorry about that
yeah that too i agree that's another
cool idea
anything else
no i think that's about it this is fun
all right we got a black one
this is supposed to happen
oh
queen h4 there's i'm sorry queen h5 and
there's no
what are you attacking
well the point is not the pawn the point
is g3 is uh g3
i can't play g3 yeah but if you pull if
you move your queen away who's defending
your knight
that's a good question
you have the right idea just need to
figure out the right move where they're
two
three pontigs
but then queen h4 meets knight 82
um
yeah wherever the knight goes this guy's
hanging yeah so another thing that you
can also do in your scanning for the
position
because in any position you should do a
quick scan to just be aware of where the
pieces are right so in this specific
case
you it's a good idea to add um the loose
pieces too this queen is nobody's
defending it so that's
realizing that might just make you
help you make smarter choices
and not just necessarily the king but
also the screen nobody's defending it so
then if there's nightmares voila so
just little stuff like that
all right
black to move what do we do
check uh
f3 check
king to the back rank uh
rook d1
check yeah
i think this is called the dovetail
mage
or arabian thanks what is the dovetail
then
i thought it was
the i'm more surprised you don't know
the arabian
why
i'm not from arabia that's true
i'll actually argue um
what is the hook mate them
see i didn't grow up with people
ah that's fair captain hook land
no island
wait seriously yeah
jesus
oh we got someone saying what a dovetail
is
fair okay
i can live with that
i like that more this is australian mate
i accept that
there we go
what about this one
any other
country names
few people in the chat are on the right
spot i think i end up
if i take
the bishop on e5 yeah
because let's say they take this guy
sure
and then they take the night
and then you take them
yeah
good choice sometimes you just have to
eat and not checkmate
what about here
bishop
g1
whoa and then rook takes g1 rook
uh h2
uh all right okay uh queen f2
uh group blocks and then rook h8
beautiful
nice nicely done
sorry whatnot
you want to start with turkish that's
why
my first novel
bishop
yeah this bishop is kind of on the way
and
if your bishop and queen were in
actually that would still would have
been a little
problematic
um but still
like your position is just screaming for
some sort of an attack so all you have
to do is
figure out the right move order because
the right
idea is there so
yeah
oh this is going to be one of my
favorite ones
course noise white carpool's black on
the other day
right
it smells kind of hurtful i agree
i thought you were gonna
we couldn't resist
all right yeah night after is the best
one kind of cool right if take
yep whatever you do this line is going
to be the death of you
if you move away even better
actually i don't know which one is
prettier
than time trouble here that's why you
played for
a1
sure
that's that's how he likes to remember
the second one's prettier
yeah
but yeah some some funny ideas like that
are
just i can't remember if i've ever
played no i don't think i've ever had a
serious game like this that's sad
all right here this one is white to move
as white you have a few ideas you all
just have to figure out as which one is
better
i don't think that
meat is stoppable after queen takes king
takes
uh or checks king back to g8
knight
i'm sorry knight g3 yeah
knight f to g6 nice
yeah
no you're right i'm messing with you
yeah
yeah
the lack of development really does bite
black
so
maybe not that black of development lack
of space i guess
also why would you allow this pawn to
get this high up in your right mind
yeah i think the biggest problem with
last position is this guy
ironically
all right how about this one black to
move
while you guys are thinking what should
i do if there is a friendly raccoon who
stops by almost every night
doesn't come inside but
comes behind my door and just stares
like this and my cat goes crazy
name him i did i call it dracon
i call my cat cat just in a different
language
doesn't help that dracula and farsi
steals a raccoon
sorry whoops
i usually have alarms for remembering to
clock out i just set the wrong alarm for
now
yeah raccoons
it's really cute too i managed to get
some really cute pictures of it the
hands are a little creepy but
the face is really cute
trash
pants knife
you're just one more shirt rook h3
bishop takes ricketts too
i like this oh my eyes are back
no actually i still can't get too close
from here it's fine if i get closer
pieces start to dance again
makes it fun though
to be fair i did say a few times that
whenever i play chess i try to dance
with my pieces now my pieces are doing
it on their own like a little
these are too simple well when i do hard
you guys complain when i do openings
people complain they don't want openings
so we try to i'm trying to give you an
easy midterm exam
this hour is supposed to be fun well
just this hour next week this time i
can't promise the same because we're
gonna start the end game series so
that'll be fun
what is 4c for cat
well peachy is like the cute cat which
is why i common cat peachy uh the i
guess the more official one is gorbel
but i don't think anybody says gorba too
cats
just to confirm it is white to move
if it was blocked well actually that
would be interesting too
oh there are no ugly cats
what
well
thank you for that board guess so
i'm never coming to scotland
i'm never bringing pee my cat to
scotland there we go
p she ain't coming there
i actually tried to take pishi to
london a few months back
it did not really work out because
we got all the paperwork and everything
and
that was about to book a ticket then
airline informed me that they no longer
fly any type of animals
yeah
it was my mom really wanted to meet the
kids
okay so the chat is getting some
feelings towards
the correct move idea
it is right
check me that way check my that way yeah
is there a specific name for a move like
that
it's too cute
the only name that comes to my mind
right now is a squid or an octopus
because it's like
taking care of everything in that
situation
right and defending in so many ways you
could call it
sabotage
it's too basic let's go with octopus
i like this octopus
there we go maybe
yeah i can't really think of how black
would stop this
i mean
the only thing he could do here to
continue his play
bishop takes
three times
oh this should be two uh maybe but i'll
just take that
still check my ideas
maybe rook g8
but again still yeah this is this is
pretty dead all right black to move
ah this is
cute really cute
it's so cold in this corner
chest weave if you're closed can you
like raise the temperature by five
degrees or so
i have no idea how you're sitting here
with this short sleeve
i can't get enough layers
that's the idea but we still have to
prepare for it
we need another thing before we can go
through it through the back rank
i do need a blanket maybe just a small
heater here would be good too
who wants to play g4 why
i or c1 but if you play g4 what if a
pawn just plays
g3
well then the bishop falls what if g4
just they just take it
the problem with queen takes rook is
queen takes it then what do you do
yeah pretty much
you are correct
we have to be very cautious about how we
play this
sorry
oh
oh uh does
does rook d1 check with the idea that if
the rook cannot move
uh
without
the rookie one check bishop takes um
knight takes and then we have a double
attack on the rook c1 king g
sorry rook c8 king king g7 and the queen
cannot check because the knight covers
the two squares between check
what if queen just takes your mind
you all have the right idea wanting to
do something in the back rank but
the what the what of it seems to be a
bit of a disagreement
[Music]
what if rook c8 check
you move the cane then the jeep pawn
like g3
uh even if you like king h7 what if they
just played g3
not ideal
there is another idea
do you still want to do stuff in the
background but you need a little bit of
a more
more of a the
specificity
so how can you attack the rook
without moving your rook
could be
but knight day four
[Music]
maybe just rook to e3
that would also prove to be slightly
problematic
okay so
i discounted knight d1 nice but
after bishop takes queen a1 and then you
have a double
attack on the on the bishop
it should be
no that is funny you're right
nice job
now the thing is well if bishop takes it
hallelujah
that would be fun
if bishop doesn't take it they have to
move the rook if they move the rook then
queenie run so
sometimes you just gotta eat yeah good
choice
is there any confusion on it still
all right let's move on
again black to move
again you see the king is in the middle
there's some funny business happening
here
so the ideas are there all you gotta do
is just
figure out the exact move order for it
i'm going to clear up the arrows
fits
the chat seems to be
huh
this feels weird
right can't take this
can't take that can't take that
yeah
i think the best thing to do is just
resign at this point
or
no i like this this is fun
yeah good job
why to move
the king is still weak but that's also
not the only thing on the board
opponents
development is just
a lot of funny things are happening
right now
i wish i could do this but i don't want
to give this up
i wish i could throw this off the board
so i could move my knight and attack
this guy somehow 96 is the person
but it's really
still got yeah still got to go deeper on
it because if 96 would have just taken
against the queen
yeah i i think i mean i i feel like you
just got to spend a little bit more time
on it
not necessarily wrong
so when you look at a bar like this are
you looking you're looking for the
undefended pieces you're looking for a
way to be a person check
you're looking
how are you evaluating
uh
how am i evaluating well i guess what
i'm trying to do is
um
i really want to be able to
figure out how to
attack but i don't want to start jumping
off
oh
come on chat give me a minute
no sorry um what i'm trying to do is
first i try to identify opponent's
weaknesses so this is this is loose this
is loose
this is loose but so is mine
so
the other problem is if i do some chill
idea like this to try to defend this guy
then my d5 could fall or like they could
just move the queen somewhere else or
they could push push the bishop
somewhere else and so it's a very
dynamic position and i can't i don't
have the luxury
to um
to wait on it so it means that i need to
go a little bit faster so i'm gonna need
to start thinking of more challenging
ideas such as knight e6 now the main
thing about 96 to figure out is what a
pawn takes
yeah that's fair attacking this guy
attacking this guy
let's say
queen moves then
say knight d6 takes g5 queen moves
are you still comfortable with this idea
i see a very strong knot so sure
take this
take this this pawn is beautiful all i
got to do is
somehow get my queen here yeah seems
doable
yeah this is a very very comfortable
position
it might not be checkmate just yet but
all right how about this one
why to move again your position seems to
be just a bit better your knight isn't
your knight is in the center you're
attacking
see i can't see where i'm clicking this
is painful
it's getting better but
uh your knight is better if this king is
weaker than your king your pieces seem
to be more available for the attack but
at the same time
how do you actually do it
and for
argument just let me close this part up
uh
square
it's most of what i'm trying to do
how many attackers
so you're committing to rookie 7 yeah
rook d7
rook e7 knight takes knight takes
uh
well i guess why would you take
do you have to take i guess that's a
that's a question that i have
does the
queen move
well i guess um
rookie 7 97 you don't have to take it
just yet
there's their check options too the only
thing i want you to consider is just
those check options
the knights over there you can check
with the knight
yeah check out the night off that would
be more forceful
you have the right idea but
pretty much every single square is wrong
sorry
sorry for making
you ha i mean i understood you you're
correct but
thank you thank you
i like this because if queen takes then
you pick this guy up and then pick this
guy up and
what else do i want
um
yes maybe queen better queen b6 i'll
just move it away never mind
i mean this is still comfortable but
still need some work i don't like that
this thing
so instead of knife
immediately tonight uh queen takes b7
then queen takes p7 then knight checks
nice
i think so yeah this feels quite
comfortable as well
yeah i think that's fair that's a fair
um
idea here
i'm fine with this
let's see
get back here
rookie seven i agree
a 97 first still does work i guess
somehow
let's see what does the big guy say
whoa
ah too fast
no no
i'm not getting i'm not getting into
that
i agree with your first idea
and i do like this guy
i'm fine with this too
yeah this is cool too
booty goody
i mean
if this is
i could just eat this actually
yeah but they
they take it the problem is they have
this ouch
they have this king over here
yeah your advantage gets really less
yeah
but i think that's
and well not in that line come on
computer
no
just take this guy
in this position okay 7 you're very
comfortable
attacking this if they move the
knight can i just
eat this and maybe eat this i don't know
they can eat this oh no actually they
can't eat that because i have bishop
pizza and there we go huh
yeah this is very comfortable
all right
let's do one more and wrap it up because
i do have to analyze ah man
some games
so if you don't have your games ready
just yet go ahead and have them ready
because we are going to be switching to
twitch analyzing your game if you have
not played any cool games recently we'll
play one now
yeah chat founders at the same time too
nice
what do we want checkmate when do we
want it
and we also want to rook
how can you win these how can they even
ah maybe
no i'll still do this
maybe king up
i have to make a queen this would be fun
too but i can't really find a good
checkmate so let's just make the queen
no queen
yeah
it's unfortunate
but yeah this is checkmate is very
pretty all right everybody this was fun
thank you for
being around and
if you have a game
show up on twitch we'll do that if not
well just hang around on twitch with us
have a great rest of your night
[Music]
you